Dustin is in Madison Wisconsin hi Dustin
how are you I'm doing all right how
about yourself better than I deserve
what's up all right I'm a pretty
analytical person and about six months
ago I almost did something and buy a
house I decided to do my first budget
and realized how stupid I was being with
my money and realize that was going to
be a really bad idea at my current
situation no after that I decided I
wanted to learn more about budgeting
financing and stuff like that I just
filled in the podcast and stuff and
that's how I came across you okay now
I'm gonna lose people I like to share
what I know and I was just curious
what's a good way to get my friends
involved too it's one of those things
where in a group I think it's more
supportive mm-hmm and I think they'll
fall feel better okay I plan on taking
FPU for myself the home study mm-hmm I
just haven't got it quite yet yeah and I
want to share some of those what might
be your lead FPU is a home group for a
bunch of your friends if you could get
them to join or start it at your church
and get them to join there however that
works for you that's a way that that's
one of the reasons Financial Peace
University works is you're right you're
onto something when people are in a
group a supportive group where they're
holding you accountable and encouraging
you
it changes your your probability of
behavior modification is way up versus
sitting in your living room by yourself
looking at the screen right and so yep
the read that'sthat's really the the
reason that Financial Peace University
has been so successful it's not my
teaching or my beauty it's not my
haircut you know so yeah for sure
but the but but you know it is the fact
that people get in each other's lives
and go no you can't do that or you got
this man you can do it you know they
you're encouraging or you're holding
accountable that that's the magic to it
so to speak
and now as far as talking to someone
about it I had an experience the other
day when Sharon and I had been married
about 10 years we hit the wall and
almost killed each other and ended up
going to a marriage counselor it saved
our lives and our marriage and and I
read a bunch of marriage books about
that time as well
just to learn how to be married because
I really was a pretty sucky husband and
so I was learning how to do it better
and so I was sitting and sitting with
one of my friends the other day he was
talking about his marriage is not doing
good and so I didn't go we start wagging
my finger and going well you're stupid
you ought to do this you ought to do
that you're out of control you do you
know this and that and this and that
instead I just talked about the dumb
things that I had done and some of the
things I learned so that I quit doing
dumb things and the result was our
marriage is a whole lot better like a
bazillion times better right and I said
you know the book that helped me is this
book and I handed him one of those books
you know and and I handed him you know
love and respect another book from my
friend egg rich they wrote that book
it's a great marriage book and so on so
you know that's the way you do it you
talk about when you messed up not how
messed up they are and that you you know
like out you just told me a great story
I almost bought a house because I was
stupid but when I sat down and looked at
where I was it saved me from making a
really bad financial decision and inside
when you're look talking to your friend
who's making bad financial decisions
they're thinking to themselves well
that's me I make bad financial decisions
all the time but you don't have to wag
your finger at them and go you're stupid
that they already come to that
conclusion pretty quick you know what
I'm saying oh yeah so it it it's a it's
a methodology for persuasion that's very
that pulls people rather than pushes
them and it doesn't say you need this
class you ought to go to this class now
I can say that on the radio but you
can't say that one-on-one with your
friends right and why don't one with
your friends are going
I needed this class and it really helped
me and it you know and if you want to
come I'm gonna be doing the class and
man I would be honored if you and your
wife sat in and you know that kind of a
thing but you don't need to go you're
stupid if you don't come this class
you're gonna keep being stupid that's
just not a method for persuasion it
doesn't work and people try that though
all the time I had a friend tell me try
to tell me the same thing about
nutrition one time he started just
telling me all the stuff I was doing
wrong and I'm like you know what you
know your your color is so bad you look
like you need a steak and that was my
answer to him you know
like when these vegetarian characters
and so I'm just like dude you need to
eat a steak and shut the conversation
down now I didn't really solicit his
advice and he comes in and starts
telling me wearing me out about eating
carrots you know and so you know people
don't want your advice but if you tell
them your story about the time you
messed up and then when you stop messing
up how your life got better they relate
to that they connect to that and it's
winsome it draws them in and it's not
manipulation it's just how we
communicate properly on areas that are
sensitive like money or marriage or
parenting or whatever you know it's just
very difficult subjects to talk about
religion people don't want to talk about
religion you know and you know if you
just want to pick a fight you can pick a
fight any of those areas are pretty easy
to pick but that's not what you're
trying to do Dustin to your credit
you're trying to involve your friends
and it is kind of different than
recommending a movie you know we went
and saw Jason Bourne the other day it's
a good movie and you know you just got a
recommendation just like that okay you
know but it's not like gonna change your
life
and it's not the antidote to something
you're doing wrong in your life it's
just a movie and it's kind of like
another Bourne movie they're fairly
predictable several people get killed
and Jason kills them I mean it's not you
know it's like watching a set it's like
watching 24 or something you know I mean
somebody's gonna die you know it's like
we kind of know this going into the
theater right so but it's worth seeing
it's a good movie if you like I'm action
flick you know if you like the other
borns or like that one I think so but
but that's a different kind of a
recommendation than ret me recommending
a marriage book to my friend who's
stubbing his toe in his marriage right
now and the way you phrase that and the
way you get at that conversation is
completely different so good question
man it's an honor to talk to you and I
appreciate you being a listener in
Madison Wisconsin appreciate you hanging
out
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below
you